foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory what do you know about
Diagon Alley because it's far more than
just a shopping center for Britain's
Wizards and witches Diagon Alley's
history stretches back hundreds of years
and survived countless Goblin rebellions
Wars with dark Wizards and even witch
hunts today we're going to take a look
at Diagon Alley's secret history and
find out how it came to be Medieval era
nobody really knows when the first store
opened its doors in Diagon Alley but
rest assured there have been quite a few
theories after all we know that
gringott's Wizarding Bank was
established in 1474 just a century after
the famous economic crash That Shook The
Wizarding World to its core it would
make sense if Diagon Alley developed
after the Goblins established such a
massive Financial Center Gringotts would
eventually become one of the most
important daily fixtures in the entire
Wizarding World of Britain and hundreds
of wizards would regularly visit on a
daily basis establishing an apothecary
or one shop nearby was a sure way to
catch customers who had galleons to
spend but others might think the Diagon
Alley got its start on the day the Leaky
cauldron opened its doors it's written
within that Pub's very address or so it
seems since the Leaky cauldron's posted
address is number one Diagon Alley many
Wizarding historians opposed that the
establishment of the famous pub inin
marked the beginning of Diagon Alley but
the truth is probably somewhere in
between sometime in the Medieval Era the
part of London that would eventually
become Diagon Alley must have been
popular with local witches and wizards
perhaps even then when it was just a
mud-filled street with a few Cobblestone
patches ollivander's one shop and a few
other magical vendors decided to plant
their Roots eventually the area must
have become so well known amongst
Wizards that the Goblins of the era
decided to construct gringott's Bank
there and then all of the other shops
which Harry and his friends knew so well
surely followed suit Evolution now of
all the places in The Wizarding World
Diagon Alley strangely avoided the
history books for most of its existence
in fact it wasn't until the second Rise
of Voldemort and the start of Harry
Potter's Journey at Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry that the street
shows up often in record chords but as
we often like to do we can certainly
make a few educated guesses as to how
this street evolved with so much of the
Wizarding world's wealth concentrated in
a single Street the stores that
developed around it were crucial for the
everyday life of witches and wizards by
this point in time Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry had been open
for some centuries although the schools
still lacked many of the familiar facets
that Harry Potter would come to love
during his time there Hogwarts was quite
well known in Britain and attending that
school or any other school was important
for the 28 purebred families that
populated the British Isles which meant
they'd do anything to make sure their
child had the best robes wands and
potion supplies and where were they
going to buy those items if not Diagon
Alley during this era the ancestors of
some of the most famous wizards of the
20th century frequented Diagon Alley as
they prepared their children for the
coming school year if you walked around
any Corner you'd be sure to find a gang
of Sirius Black's forefathers or James
Potter's great great great great
grandparents you'd likely even find a
few Weasleys or Malfoy's who came up
from France during the Norman conquest
list of shops by the time Harry Potter
journeyed to Diagon Alley along with
rubius Hagrid the entire Street was
filled with dozens of stores from menu
and sis quills to elops Owl Emporium and
after the international statute of
Wizarding secrecy the street became even
harder to find as it was concealed
behind countless enchantments and charms
over the centuries innumerable stores
popped up alongside gring gods and added
to the culture of the alley so let's
take a moment and peruse through a few
of these if you were in the mood for
tricks and jokes you'd be best served by
Gamble and Japes Wizarding joke shop
before Fred and George left Hogwarts to
open their own store the Weasley twins
would often visit gambling James to
gather all they would need to terrorize
August Felch during the upcoming school
year the store held hundreds of items
but they were most famous for Dr
filibuster's fabulous wet stance no heat
fireworks which could be ignited with
just a bit of water and if you needed
some of the fine supplies for class you
could stop by the magical Menagerie
located on the north side of Diagon
Alley right across from the sweet shop
where Hagrid bought Harry a cone of
chocolate and raspberry ice cream the
magical Menagerie carried almost every
type of magical pet in The Wizarding
World there were puff skin crested toads
ferrets bats and of course owls Ron and
Hermione would often visit the magical
Menagerie whenever they needed to get
ointments or digestive cures for their
pants now if you had a sharp eye you
might notice that among the many Artisan
stores within Diagon Alley there were
plenty of second-hand shops as well from
secondhand robes to secondhand books any
Wizard or witch on a budget would have
found anything they needed but if you
had galleons to spend you were welcome
to use them too at Madame malkin's robes
for All Occasions you could find
expertly crafted robes and dresses and
at ollivander's one shop you could get
your hands on the most important tool a
wizard would ever need his wand the one
shop claimed to have been in operation
since 382 BC but whether they had been
in Diagon Alley all that time or had
moved there after having set up shop
somewhere else was one of the hottest
debates among historians of the time as
you might recall ollivanders crafted the
Harry Potter's wand which just so
happened to be the twin to Lord
voldemorts as he wandered around the
district you'd also notice that there
were plenty of businesses that weren't
really open to the public these were the
officers of some of the most important
Publishers in The Wizarding World from
the daily Prophet to the ministry press
even obscurious books the Publishers
behind Fantastic Beasts and Where to
Find Them had an office in the alley if
you want a list of all of the shops in
Diagon Alley leave a comment down below
spin-offs but when you walked around
Diagon Alley you might notice there were
a few odd twists and turns that might
tempt you off the main street if you
took any of those routes you might find
yourself at a less reputable Market that
intersected Diagon Alley one of these
nocturnali would send a shiver down any
normal Wizard or witch this street was
famous for housing shops that sold dark
relics and magical items its most famous
shop Morgan and Berks was even a
temporary employer for a young Tom
Riddle That shop held no shortage of
dangerous eye
from cursed necklaces to the hand of
Glory but just like the main District of
Diagon Alley Nocturne had plenty of
other shops to tempt a dark Wizard or
wench in fact by the time Harry Potter
enrolled at Hogwarts knocked her Nelly's
reputation seemed to obeyed as many
purebred families shop there instead of
diagonally amongst nocturne's many shops
there were dark Relic vendors like Cobb
and Webb shiver wretches Venoms and
poisons for all of your nefarious needs
and even a dark alternative to the Leaky
cauldron a palm but known as the white
wyvern but Nocturne was just one of the
many offshoots from the main Diagon
Alley District if you needed to find a
new house elf you could always venture
to the nearby District of kharkit
markets where the house elf placement
agency would sort you out or if you
wanted to buy the perfect troll puppet
for your nephew or niece you could go to
horizontally and visit periwinkle's
plaything
where their wide array of toys and
marionettes Drew long lines conclusion
Diagon Alley was the Beating Heart Of
The Wizarding Community besides Hogwarts
there was hardly any other place where
so many Wizards could comfortably go
about town embracing the most joyful
part of the magical world whether they
were taking a family stroll to Sugar
Plum's sweet shop for a nice Sunday trip
or scheduling their summer vacation at
the office of territores Diagon Alley
was as important for wizards as just
about anything else in their lives and
even though the streets of the shopping
district often cleared out during times
of conflict as they did during Lord
Voldemort's second Rise they'd come
right back to life as soon as the coast
was clear and that's it for this video
what do you think of Diagon Alley of all
the places in The Wizarding World is
this on the top of your must-see list
let me know in the comments below until
next time remember it is the quality of
one's convictions that determine success
not the number of followers
[Music]